good morning believe nation if you feel
like you don't have the resources the
money the connections the experience to
take the idea that you have and make it
a reality and a success I'm going to
share with you a clip from Chris Gardner
that I think will help you I'll never
forget a recent experience
doing my business on Wall Street getting
on the train to come back to midtown one
o'clock in the afternoon normally
there's a lo this train should be empty
but on this day the train was full full
of people all in businesses a guy
recognizes me comes over says hey are
you Chris Gardner we started talking
about turns out I'm in the car with the
first wave of the 55,000 people who had
just been laid off by Citibank and I
noticed something everyone's holding up
box you've seen the boxes you've seen
them on television they've got the house
plant the coffee mug the pictures of
their kids and they're all going home
they're all going home to tell their
wife their husband their children and
the landlord they don't have a job I
began to share with this young guy that
do you know what yeah you lost your job
but you haven't lost your skills your
talent or your expertise but we've got
to do now is create opportunities where
the skilled talent and expertise can be
transferable creating an opportunity and
looking for a job are two different
things
this could be prime time for pushing
your button rather finding your button
what do I mean by that prime time to
find that one thing that you love to do
so much you would get up in the morning
and do it free prime time to find that
one thing that the Sun cannot comes up
soon enough in the morning because you
want to go do your thing this could be
that time in your life so my quick take
on this is you've got Chris Gardner
right you got a guy you went from being
homeless to being worth millions and so
many entrepreneurs what they do is you
focus on what you don't have you focus
on the resources that you don't have you
focus on the connections that you don't
have you focus on all
things that you don't have where instead
what you need to do is focus on your
resourcefulness because while you may be
limited in your resources you should be
limitless in your resourcefulness at
least you should be if you want to be
successful as an entrepreneur the key is
to stop thinking about what you don't
have and start thinking about what you
can do with what you do have if Chris
Gardner can go from being homeless to
being a millionaire you can overcome
whatever you've convinced yourself that
you're missing in your business to start
being successful the key is to change
your mindset start where you are and
start with what you have believe thank
you guys for watching my question of the
day for you is I want to know I want to
know what excuse is holding you back
right now I want to know what voice in
your head you're telling yourself I
can't be successful because I don't have
blank I want to know what that blank is
what that story is that you're telling
yourself leave a comment below I'm
really curious to find out of course if
you guys like this video and you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and the newsletter have a
fantastic day and I hope to see you
again tomorrow morning at 7 a.m. for
another inspirational video to kickstart
your day belief